مناطق وفي كراماتورز لقسم روسي وحول تلك
التطورات ينضم الينا من هناك مراسلنا حسان
مسعود حسان ما الذي استهدفه هذا القصف
والاضرار نشاهدها من خلفك واضحه
نعم مريم بالفعل مدينه كما تورس مره جديده
تتعرض لقصف صاروخي هذا القصف طال مباني
سكنيه وسط المدينه سنشاهد اثار الدمار
الكبير الذي احدثته هذه الصواريخ التي
اطلقت بي اتجاه هذه المنطقه ونشاهد هنا
اثار الصواريخ هذه هي
بعض مخلفات الصواريخ التي اطلقت على هذه
المنطقه وخلفت دمارا كبيرا في هذه المباني
السكنيه وهذه المباني مريم عندما تم القصف
كانت مسكونه ببعض السكان ما ادى الى اصابه
ثلاثه على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه وفق
المعطيات الاوليه
وهذا القصف اتى صباح اليوم عند الساعه
التاسعه تقريبا صباحا
بالتوقيت المحلي ما
ابدا الى هذا هذه الاصابات البشريه وكذلك
في ذات الوقت تم اجلاء السكان من هذه
المباني ليس في هذا المبنى فقط انما ايضا
في عدد من المباني التي تضررت بفعل هذا
القصف الصاروخي الذي يستمر على مناطق غرب
مباخمت في عمق المناطق التي منها يتم
تزويد المقاتلين في منطقه باخموت بالدعم
والتعزيزات التي تتواصل بشكل مستمر طيله
الوقت في
في المعركه المتواصله في مدينه لكن هذا
القصف كما يبدو وكما هو واضح طالما منطقه
سكنيه هذه المره بعدما كان قد طال منشات
حيويه خلال الايام الماضيه لاسيما في
منطقه سلافيانسك التي ايضا تعتبر من
المناطق الواقعه في عمق المنطقه الغربيه
لمنطقه باخموت صاله سكه الحديد لكن هذا
القصف اليوم هنا في منطقتي كراماتورسك كما
نشاهد ادى الى هذا الضرر الكبير في منطقه
حيويه سكنيه فيها عدد من المباني تضررت
حتى هذه اللحظه سته مباني على الاقل في
هذا القصف الذي ايضا علق عليه الرئيس
الاوكراني قبل قليل بان القوات الروسيه
تشن ما وصفها بالهجمات الارهابيه على
مناطق المدنيين وتؤدي الى اثار وضرر على
السكان ونشاهد ايضا هذه المباني هنا التي
تضررت بما فيها ايضا السيارات
التي ادت الى هذه الاصابات التي تحدثنا
عنها ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه الحصيله
النهائيه ما زالت غير معلنه بشكل كامل
نظرا لوجود اعمال رفع للركام وحصل الاضرار
حسان مسعود منكراماتورس شكرا لك